Дебати між Петром Порошенком та Володимиром Зеленським -
чи не найочікуваніша подія після першого туру президентських виборів.
Відбудуться вони чи ні - досі залишається гол овною інтригою.
Але свій "відеобаттл" кандидати вже, по суті, розпочали.
Ви кличете мене на дебати. Мріяли, що я втечу, "відморожусь", сховаюсь.
Ні, я - це не Ви у 14-му році.
Я приймаю виклик.
Чекаю на вас тут, на НСК "Олімпійський".
Дебати - це не шоу.
Виборча кампанія - це подія, яка визначає майбутнє країни і нації на роки і десятиліття вперед.
Але стадіон, так стадіон.
Чи можливе проведення дебатів на стадіоні? Теоретично так.
Однак тоді це вже не будуть теледебати, прописані у законі "Про вибори президента України",
а просто дебати як форма передвиборчої агітації, пояснюють у Центральній виборчій комісії.
За законом, передвиборчі теледебати мають відбуватися на Суспільному телеканалі,
а їхня організація оплачується з державного бюджету.
Тоді як дебати на стадіоні, як і будь-яка передвиборча агітація,
мають фінансуватися з виборчих фондів кандидатів, наголошують у ЦВК.
У будь-якому випадку, за чинним законодавством, участь у дебатах є добровільною,
а відмова від них не має якихось юридичних наслідків для кандидатів.
Запрошенням на дебати в ультимативній формі Володимир Зеленський
фактично перетворює передвиборчу кампанію на шоу -
власне, те, чим він займається професійно, зазначають німецькі оглядачі.
На їхню думку, нині в Україні надто великий ажіотаж довкола дебатів.
Адже головне - це чесність та демократичність виборів,
а не питання, де мають пройти дебати - у телестудії чи на стадіоні.
Для дебатів важливі ораторські здібності кандидатів, змістовність їхніх відповідей,
а також, хто буде ведучим, які питання він ставитиме та чиїх прихильників під час дискусії буде більше.
В Україні дебати між кандидатами у президенти проходили лише двічі.
Уперше - між Леонідом Кравчуком та Леонідом Кучмою у 1994 році.
А вдруге - у 2004-му - між Віктором Ющенком та Віктором Януковичем.
Ці руки нічого не крали.
Але тоді дебати суттєво не вплинули на суспільну думку,
і прихильники обох претендентів вважали, що переміг саме їхній кандидат.
Найбільше у дебатах зацікавлений саме Порошенко,
адже він - кращий промовець і сподівається завоювати у другому турі виборців,
які ще вагаються або голосували за інших кандидатів.
Для політичного початківця Зеленського участь у дебатах невигідна, наголошують оглядачі.
Вони вважають, що політрадники Зеленського зроблять усе можливе,
щоб уникнути його участі у відкритому двобої з Порошенком на телебаченні.
Свідчення цьому - висунення різного роду ультиматумів
з дещо дивними вимогами - як-то медичні довідки.
Дебати між кандидатами - частина політичної культури у багатьох західних країнах.
Вони нерідко змінювали перебіг виборів - так, приміром, сталося в США у 1960 році.
Переможцем перегонів тоді став молодий та впевнений лідер Джон Кеннеді,
саме таким його побачили телеглядачі - на противагу РІчарду Ніксону.
Але, приміром, у 2016 році саме Гілларі Клінтон, за оцінками багатьох експертів,
виглядала значно переконливіше, ніж Дональд Трамп, і виграла теледебати.
Утім, на виборах програла Трампу.
Неабиякі пристрасті кипіли на теледебатах під час останніх президентських перегонів у Франції.
Тоді переможцем словесного "двобою" телеглядачі визнали
відносно новачка у політиці Еммануеля Макрона,
він же згодом і став президентом країни.